The small striped chipmunk lives in the mountains.
Does anything else live in the mountains?
Yes, the small gray squirrel lives in the mountains.
Yes, the small furry rabbit lives in the mountains.
Does anything else live in the mountains?
Yes, the small sly fox lives in the mountains.
Yes, the big strong eagle lives in the mountains.
Does anything else live in the mountains?
Yes, the big proud deer lives in the mountains.
Yes, the big hungry bear lives in the mountains.
Does anything else live in the mountains?
Yes, many animals live in the mountains.
Can you name these animals that live in the mountains?
Where do small striped chipmunks live?
Small striped chipmunks live in the mountains.
Do small furry rabbits live in the mountains, too?
Yes, they do.
Do giant blue whales also live in the mountains?
No, they don't. They live in the sea.